si vous êtes là Fabien d'abord c'est
parce que vous avez un objectif
exceptionnel que vous allez nous montrer
dans quelques instants un objet qui
appartenu à Michael Jackson que personne
n'a vu encore absolument personne ne l'a
vu vous nous l'avez réservé sera mis en
vente le 2 décembre aux enchères et vous
êtes devenu un expert comme vous êtes
experts de la chanson française depuis
12 ans absolument tout à faites d'objets
appartenu à des célébrités des costumes
de scène des manuscrits des disques d'or
enfin tout ce qui appartenu des trophées
comme ça des artistes et depuis 12 ans
je fais ça pour les tribunaux je fais
des reconstitutions de carrière pour les
tribunaux aussi quand il y a des litiges
entre artistes et mais ils ont disques
et quand il y a des successions que ce
soit Juliette Gréco Patrick juvex ce
soit Maurice Chevalier enfin tous ceux
qui nous ont quittés et voilà
j'interviens pour donner des valeurs des
estimations dans le cadre de donation de
succession ou tout simplement de vente
parce que la chanson française n'a pas
de secret pour vous et vous sortez ce
livre vos prénoms en chanson sa cartonne
donc vous voulez absolument vous
recevoir c'est vrai que l'idée est
extrêmement originale un prénom une
chanson est-ce que tout le monde a son
prénom dans une chanson non alors
justement il y a des il y a des gens qui
n'ont pas de
penser à vous il y en a une donc Canada
qui s'appelle Pascal enchanté Simard par
exemple moi j'en ai pas en tout cas je
suis pas chanson sur Fabien existe pas
Isabelle il y en a eu quelques unes
[Musique]
je t'aime et puis après on n'en connaît
pas d'autres alors bien sûr
absolument absolument exactement
Alexandre pour lui Alexandre
[Musique]
ça c'est une grande grande chanson qui
est toujours dans les 10 titres les plus
joués en discothèque depuis 43 ans
en discothèque les plus joués encore et
d'autres chansons de Claude François
aussi qui continuent de vivre évidemment
et puis cette année-là et puis je vais à
Rio et puis tous les derniers tubes de
sa carrière évidemment parce qu'il reste
un des leaders en tout cas dans un
répertoire français il y a une il y a
une artiste qui s'appelle Juliette
Armanet qui est sorti une chanson qui
s'appelle Alexandre
ah ben on va la chercher bon ben j'ai
compris dans la dans la polémique Sardou
Armanet cet été mais j'ai pris sa
défense parce que je trouve qu'elle a le
droit de s'exprimer une opinion n'est
pas un délit en France donc elle pense à
elle pense bien qu'elle pense mal on
sait pas Sardou lui a donné la main
d'ailleurs en disant mais elle a dit
très bien il a été formidable Sardou
parce qu'il a dit moi aussi j'ai dit des
conneries Sardou
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec elle
mais elle a le droit de s'exprimer si
elle pense ça elle a le droit de le dire
Alexandre la chanson de Juliette on l'a
trouvé
[Musique]
ça y est bien sûr voilà
mais voilà
une chanson pour Sacha
ça veut dire Sacha
Distel en
prénoms
c'est très très vieux mais Sacha
Alexandre donc je prends les chansons
d'Alexandre ça me va et moi non
Pascal
oui non
toujours pour rien voilà la grande
phrase de Patrick Bruel
sont les prénoms les plus utilisés dans
la chanson française alors alors ça
dépend des époques par exemple on
parlait d'Isabelle par exemple Isabelle
c'est un des plus vieux prénoms comme
Jeanne en France c'est les prénoms qui
remontent au Moyen-Âge subliminal non
absolument
ça dépend mais ça revient il y a des
modes les prénoms Marie tiens temporels
etc et enfin on sait pas si c'est une
chanson qui fait qu'on vous donne un
prénom ou si c'est votre prénom qui fait
qu'on fait une chanson c'est comme
l'oeuf et la poule on sait pas qui a
commencé le premier en fait il y en a un
qui commence pourtant et donc en fait
par exemple Céline Dion la plus connue
Céline par exemple elle s'appelle Céline
elle aurait dû s'appeler Nathalie Céline
Dion parce qu'en fait sa maman c'était
son 13e enfant avec le même papa même
mère parce que je précise dans notre
époque évidemment donc elle est née en
1968 en mars 68 Céline Dion et elle
voulait l'appeler Nathalie Thérèse Dion
et puis quand elle a entendu la chanson
du gaufrey au Canada Céline elle a dit
je pleure Nathalie je vais l'appeler
Céline voilà comment elle s'appelle
Céline Dion c'est à dire que et là c'est
vraiment une chanson qui influence
voilà un ordre voilà enfin c'est
intéressant quand Johnny chante marie en
2002 par exemple
l'état civil on enregistre à peu près 90
000 maris dans les 24 mois qui suivent
pareil pour Aïcha par exemple Aïcha
cette merveilleuse chanson de Khaled par
exemple derrière c'est c'est 54000 Aïcha
qui était comme le tout le monde le sait
la l'épouse du prophète Mahomet un seul
coup ça relance toute une nuit toute une
histoire toute une puis après ça tombe
et puis ça revient et ça revient c'est
amusant vous pouvez vous pouvez en
famille vous amuser réécouter
effectivement des extraits qui sont liés
à votre prénom je voudrais maintenant
parce que vraiment vous faites ce
plaisir ce grand plaisir le coeur que
vous nous montriez cet objet alors
attendez des gants alors je vous donne
une paire de gants si vous voulez voilà
tenez voilà
on en a parlé un peu voilà un peu j'ai
un peu préparé les missions Isabelle
c'est ça la question alors
je vous ai amené une chose merveilleuse
alors cet appartenu à Michael Jackson
voilà alors ça c'est des ça c'est
absolument exceptionnel voilà je sais
pas voilà c'est les chaussures qu'il
portait Michael Jackson le 7 et le 10
septembre 2001 au Madison Square Garden
de New York quand il a célébré à ce
moment-là c'est 30 ans de de carrière
elles sont bien évidemment signées elles
sont signées alors voilà je vais faire
ça voilà sans signer all my love Michael
Jackson elles ont été des deux côtés il
a signé les deux chaussures et elle
Michael Jackson sur tous les a offertes
à son régisseur à l'époque qui a qui l'a
accompagné pendant ces deux jours où il
y avait pléthore d'artistes américains
qui est venu rendre hommage aussi à
Michael Jackson et puis elles ont été
vendues en 2011 donc deux ans après la
disparition de Michael c'est un Français
qui les a acheté qui le revend
aujourd'hui sont vendu chez couteau
begarry le 2 décembre
dans une vente aux enchères à Drouot à
Paris hyper bon état
quelle taille quelle taille de pied
alors je sais pas je ne sais pas si je
sais pas si c'est du 7 et demi du 8 et
demi parce que c'est pas marqué c'est
une marque américaine donc
combien excusez-moi mais combien ça
coûte une paire ça peut monter jusqu'à
combien une paire de chaussures de
Michael Jackson écouter il y en a une
qui s'est vendu chez julianotion à New
York elle est partie à peu près à 34000
euros il les avait dédicacés sous la
semelle d'ailleurs sous la semelle là il
les a signé là il les a signé sur le
côté voilà plus cher alors ça dépend ça
va monter je pense la mise à prix sera
autour de 15 16000 ça devrait monter
jusqu'à peut-être 30-40000 euros
bon c'est un feu de faut peut-être pas
insister c'est pour ça qu'on met des
gants c'est obligatoire je vous les
config je sais que vous auriez eu les
pieds de Michael Jackson entre vos mains
Pascal
feutre très particulière fédora etc
enfin ils sont pratiquement tous
numérotés il y a l'étiquette Jackson à
l'intérieur on va pas s'amuser à faire
des fautes ils sont signés la personne
l'expert je suis on refait la
traçabilité de l'objet une fois qu'on a
refait sa traçabilité c'est génial parce
que à partir de là on sait dans quelle
main il est passé on sait s'il y a un
marchand de millions on retire de la
vente tout de suite voilà mais c'est
passionnant écoutez voilà les chaussures
de Michael Jackson ont exclusivité grâce
à vous Fabien Lecoeuvre
ce sera de décembre à Paris avec couteau
begarie la célèbre maison qui fait ça
depuis des années maintenant et bien
merci infiniment de nous avoir fait
plaisir c'est ce cadeau pour pour ceux
qui nous